So, if you're in the audience today or maybe you're watching this talk in some other time or place,...
...you are a participant in the digital rights ecosystem.
Now whether you're an artist, a technologist, a lawyer or a fan, the handling of copyright directly impacts your life.
A rights management is no longer simply a question of ownership, it's a complex web of relationships and a critical part of our cultural landscape.
YouTube cares deeply about the rights of content owners,...
...but in order to give them choices about what they can do with copies, mashups and more,...
...we need to first identify when copyrighted material is uploaded to our site.
Let's look at this specific video so you can see how it works.
Two years ago, recording artist Chris Brown released the official video of his single "Forever."
A fan saw it on TV, recorded it with her camera phone, and uploaded it to YouTube.
Now because Sony Music had registered Chris Brown's video in our Content ID system, within seconds of attempting to upload the video,...
...the copy was detected, giving Sony the choice of what to do next.
But how do we know that the user's video is a copy?
Well, it starts with content owners delivering assets into our database, along with a usage policy that tells us what to do when we find a match.
We compare each upload against all of the reference files in our database.
Now, this heat map is gonna show you how the brain of the system works.
Here we can see the original reference file being compared to the user generated content.
The system compares every moment of one to the other to see if there's a match.
Now, this means that we can identify a match even if the copy used is just a portion of the original file,...
...plays it in slow motion and has degraded audio and video quality.
And we do this every time that a video is uploaded to YouTube.
And that's over 20 hours of video every minute.
When we find a match, we apply the policy that the rights owner has set down.
And the scale and the speed of this system is truly breathtaking.
We're not just talking about a few videos, we're talking about over 100 years of video every day,...
...between new uploads and the legacy scans we regularly do across all of the content on the site.
And we compare those hundred years of video, we're comparing it against millions of reference files in our database.
It would be like 36,000 people staring at 36,000 monitors each and every day, without so much as a coffee break.
Now, what do we do when we find a match?
Well, most rights owners, instead of blocking, will allow the copy to be published.
And then they benefit through the exposure, advertising and linked sales.